hey what's going on everyone Mary here
I've got some fellow adventurers with me
wrong Chris hi hi we're going to be
playing trine 3 or D as it really is
because of the first shine that's in 3d
Wow oh because you can go forward
foreground background that's exactly I'm
in like-new I'm so glad you're here
me so in trying 3d it's similar into the
previous trends if you've ever played
them which is that there's three
playable characters you can play
single-player if you want and then you
can just hot swap between the characters
to solve the puzzles or you can play it
online or local multiplayer which we're
currently doing and each person gets
their character I am playing the rogue
this is me I have arrows cool go ahead I
am oh look at my turn I am Pontius the
knight and my Cape is very solid I can
swing it's a piece of cardboard that
quickly made before I came out to
expedition and I can do this and I can
charge like that and I also get a cool
little hover shield I got tons of stuff
all right Chris let's see what you got
I'm Amadeus the wizard and I just looked
for psychedelic mushrooms in the
background with every level and don't
help at all you forgot about your secret
your secret I can make a ball hold a box
conjured from nothing it can consume us
all no anybody's played previous drives
the only other like that's pretty much
it the box is the same characters are
very similar a bit more yeah oh my god
boxes okay this is not fair this is an
early access so I do think maybe there's
gonna be some things that we might break
I've definitely I put through a few my
break like that yeah yeah um this came
out on a 21st of April and they said
it'll be a few months until it's
out out but I mean it's pretty it seems
like it's totally finished nothing is
weird about this no no where is the
camera
wonderful hey guys knock knock oh good
you're inside the cameras inside the box
now this is magical all right I'm gonna
have to get rid of that
let's trying it out um we did play
through this level a little bit before
just to kind of test it out make sure we
should you we were doing Chris knew what
he was doing with his boxes which means
I obviously do because if you played the
previous trains you'll remember that
there's little secrets hidden everywhere
so we found a lot of the secrets already
like this one back here that's pretty
great that was bold
I like very bold look so the best thing
about having boxes is obviously trolling
but the second best is literary just
filling up the kit and we know because
you they believe also a huge piece of
[ __ ] parkour this way guys come on we
know you can swimming what up
they always say the wizard is the
amphibious wizard we actually don't
listen this upskirt wizard what you
looking at I need a good I need to come
up for air how are you swimming with all
that armor I don't know man
oh you do look at you you got your
shield sort of like that cool clever
there's the only one who's wearing
appropriate clothing for underwater
not wearing appropriate clothing for
anywhere else though so we owe these are
my fish minions hello all right we need
air we should be able to smooch the fish
I have totally sure like like I was
saying there's multiple ways to sort of
play it your way through these always
are you guys gonna get over I'm gonna
glide yeah go ahead
what listen we've already played this
section I just want to make it a little
more interesting for you guys
just when you thought it was safe to
stand on there
Wow so 40 that worked out hey guys I'm
here Tice like in the middle of nowhere
watch out bargain joke oh oh I made it
oh that's crazy you guys gotta do it
come on that legend we have our wizard
idiot
I have killed myself this guy karma is
fair this one took a little bit he's
really yeah so mary shoots the exposed
kneecap then I come in with my sole odd
oh man chop his arm off I sure did know
he was there just kind of wizard make
make a box right oh no man I just catch
these rocks he throws you weren't doing
that last time alright to the dough
dizzy just like we planned
oh that one with sleeping sleeping on it
is where I'm going oh me too that hurt
that was a concussion
oh we're go dude like I should grab a
rock and throw it at his face and maybe
you do that but I'm dead okay I'm alive
now don't worry about it yeah a gently
drop box in your dresser Oh headshot
wizard the box can't be used
oh whoa as a weapon he's drunk and on
the platform oh yeah this is my Grob go
climb inside of his chest cavity
trying always waiting for us very okay
you did a great job
if only this monster knew all you had to
do it smash down the wall
why was da what an idiot
let's talk about Hugh's outfit is the
dopest the wizards conversation over new
topic we're both wearing dresses wore it
better living our lives is free and
normal people free says we can go back
to living our lives is free and normal
people it's the land of magic and wonder
so they what are we all doing yeah
there's this yep Rob you're saying that
this is our like Guilty Spark three
people three beauties majesty and
through this busy party Oh would you do
Mary Oh what very go space Oh
I assume that guy is evil what you got
it Stewart this is the part where I just
clutch a giant shard of glass to my
chest this is a safe and proper thing
for a wizard to hold on to so yeah it's
still in early access you were saying
Mary that there was you'd like run into
a bug or two with like skipping
cutscenes once but yeah I mean it's
overall a pretty pretty good looking
it's exactly what I expect out of the
trying series which is like oh really
enjoy puzzles combats interest are you
killing these doozer although if I die
hi guys mom you're the only person no I
actually I was trying to figure it out
my weakness no I'm gonna box me back I'm
gonna get you with me run away guys
there's my dead body
you let us down
Clodagh or my cape it is really stiff
here can I get up
sure sure thing let's do it get up there
yeah yeah all right you should be back
I'm almost there you know it all right
Tory goes onward your only time to shine
no problem but see this is like 3d
Dorito that we've been these we picked
them all up in the areas of huge part of
the trying series is that you can find
these collectibles in Oh No and they're
littered throughout the area and you
want to try to you know get them all and
because we had already played that
previous area they were already there
all go down you guys stay there
Oh Lord I got it but now we get to try
to find them again my face you love the
box you kind of the box is beautiful
yeah smash and stuff yep and so they're
hidden everywhere someone really obvious
like this one and then some of them are
super hidden there is one of that barrel
that's for sure and stuff oh there's one
up here go down here to this garbage
zone oh what's up bud what's that what's
up Pontius yeah I think that also helps
with the replayability of this because
once you learn how to solve the puzzle
it's not nearly as interesting but you
might find a little secret that you
didn't notice before and then that makes
it more fun they're not religious here
walk toward the screen walk towards the
screen so you can see me oh gosh hey hey
guys I'm a wizard okay there's nothing
over here cool
I remember I can do this damnit remember
one did that that was you are the worst
wizard ever ah beg to differ
Voldemort there you go suck it he's way
worse than me let's go I'm just creating
boxes I'm not like murdering we're
putting pieces of my soul into all these
barrels that I'm throwing
around and javis buffing off mm-hmm
no I think go this way yes back down
yeah that was just a little Oh what you
gotta go in there we got to get in to
smash this thing oh you got it okay rock
smash oh no it's definitely that
definitely the other thing not the
Smashing thank you
don't worry actually I thought well I
snuck in there nope oh I was trying to
be a jerk but I don't know if t get them
tender Ito's things are gloom here here
Oh watch out for trolls mm-hmm and Red
Hot Chili Peppers see when I do this
that's cool it speeds it up
I'm my own window get that somebody get
that cheetah oh oh yeah oh yeah I get
these if we go up on this thing and then
we do a little
oh you clamor nimble Mimi Drake your way
up got him
maybe me oh god fine they're not be
alarmed by the box situation Oh put the
Smashing too far your step by balance
boy cool dude hey guys look I found some
news I found some Doritos got it all
right now what well this is a puzzle you
got figure it out shut up you like you
cut I feel like I need to grapple attack
I think these little pillars Rob why
don't you break it why don't you wreck
it [ __ ] crooked
all right good good track Thanks next
box it the Brecon box it grapple it pop
it reference Mary do draw a card wait
did you want to get on this Oh
don't smash my box I will I'm gonna try
to Mary what are you doing are you
having fun with your rodeo rodeo
situation get up here
look jump on the box just literally jump
and pull yourself up stop even tying
yourself with the world oh yeah making
the things way more complicated they
need to be alright do the thing Venus
doesn't even know what's going on to you
this is so beyond your capabilities in
crest compress see though I impress
myself sometimes
alright let's go go go go man that is
not how physics work especially for this
fat-ass he's just heavy my home baby oh
you got a cannon you know use your um
shield to block that oh I know I'm gonna
do is this gonna like ricochet back to
it yeah it's just Decker not that dude
no it is shake shake
oh you see that that's good that's a
good move just like a continuing thing
or what oh yeah see this wall right here
Rob where I am you got it aim it there
almost
I smell MVP at that same spot like it
doesn't that's not MVP material yeah
yeah no big-time players making big-time
plays everybody that's what it's all
about here in trying three oh my god
let me get up there you're lost without
me yeah we need a box no don't shoot the
little glowing eyeball okay this is some
straight-up Zelda stuff right here this
guy's back doesn't want it because it
kind of locks on it has auto lock so it
basically if it doesn't want to go there
this lift definitely looks like it goes
up and down which lifts this one right
here yeah yeah all right you can't pull
it I think we need all jump almost get
you there heaven
yeah can would have been the best that
definitely would have felt all right
here you are we all standing on this one
platform guys this isn't one oh there's
something up here you see that there's a
Dorito up here is there yep
jump on my magical box good mood if we
do do it again no box there's a Dorito
right above me I can't get it honestly
it really is but yeah but I can't lift
you are you are a giant and Lord of a
man damn it here you could do here here
Rob thank you got it stop complaining
yeah well she's not a giant lord of a
man I don't see what's what's tough toe
is gonna comprehend about that you know
you're leaving every big log
you're gonna break my soul the Lord is
kind of a morphus though so oh I see
what's happening here see what I did in
a sweet ride Thanks all right wait wait
and one two that's it let's go can't get
rid of me
are we gonna go to that the tower is a
cool backdrop yeah wait wait before I do
anything else I think we can use these
yeah I just gotta smash these roots oh
I'll just fly over see ya
thanks for watching us play two or three
there's a boxer boy isn't that we give
him a buck per hours alright so that's
the end of the so currently the what do
you call it early access yes you levels
the first one starts off with you know
only everyone playing the same character
so you get the hang of each one's
abilities and then it goes into that
which is the second level you just saw
and there's challenges and other stuff
to mess around with it's on Steam early
access trying three that's right should
be coming out in a few months if you
prefer to just wait for the the whole
thing but I mean it's it's pretty cool
so far
and it even has an open-world area where
you could just like mess around like a
sandbox world where you just come and
got me the Infinity look to it it's like
this weird not beautiful trying
situation but also you can mess around
and drop boxes on people which is the
great it's real cute like that it's so
good thanks for watching guys see you
later
you